i'm prison mike  you know why they call me prison mike do  you really expect us to believe you're  somebody else do you really expect me to  not  push you up against the wall [ __ ]  all right hey hey hey that's just the  way we talk in the clink  but a lot of fun talk about prison today  but i am here to scare you straight  i am in this gay astronaut  in prison you are somebody's [ __ ]  oh and you you my friend would be  the bell of the ball don't drop the soap  don't drop the soap michael please  what's the very very worst thing about  prison don't encourage him dwight  the worst thing about prison was that  was the dementors they  were flying all over the place and they  were scary and then they come down and  they suck the soul out of your body and  at height  dementors like in harry potter no not  harry potter